there is pretty much no higher honor in
the whole of fps no compliment more
sincere
than absolutely smoking a kid
and being labeled a cheater whether it's
because you've domed someone with a
disgusting one tap or obliterated them
with an utterly obscene flick we've all
experienced a moment where we've smugly
said to ourselves
that kid definitely thinks i'm cheating
okay
but in esports there are certain crack
shots who are so infamously nutty that
they've had no choice but to learn how
to take such skepticism in stride
explain that
this is the same characteristic of what
a low fov aimbot has
all right
i'm on a gear baby
from shroudy rowdy to bilo to the 16x9
god there are certain aimers who've been
so utterly inundated with accusations
that it's essentially become synonymous
with their play styles it's been like
this for the most part of my
cs career i guess so
i couldn't really give a [ __ ] but it's
safe to say that of all the sus as
face slappers who are regularly turning
kids into twitch clips
none have leaned into the rumors quite
as brazenly as mason
symphony lanier you might try to get a
top tower on the same fly yeah one top
tower
for his impeccable tracking wow
inspiring wall bangs and let's be honest
his frown inducing flicks symphony isn't
downplaying the fact that people think
he's cheating
no he's flexing it to the point that
it's become his brand you guys loved my
hacking reaction so i brought a special
guest to react to him hi do you think i
cheat yeah no every morning when i bring
him his coffee i set it down i sit
behind him
these red boxes all over his screen then
there's lines everywhere
and yeah so that's literally not true
they're actually going to believe you
the question of course
is why
is it playful posturing a form of
deflection
or is it a stroke of genius
all right okay real quick is
he's baiting everyone and it's working
if i didn't know symphony bro
if i didn't live with the kid
like and i saw this for the first time i
would think he's hacking so how is it
that symphony became so controversially
cracked why did he decide to own the
cheating accusations and what exactly
has all of this spicy speculation done
for his career
got him down inside
inside crack
one one cracked inside oh my god
all right so before we snap straight on
to symphony story and start peppering it
through a wall i gotta ask that you
lovely people like the video subscribe
to the channel and turn on notifications
it wouldn't be a cheating allegations
video if we didn't use it as an
opportunity to farm those sweet
scandalous views alright so if you're a
true edgy e-gamer such as moi and
admittedly don't spend a ton of time
browsing the war zone tab on twitch
you might genuinely be wondering
who in the hell
is symphony what the [ __ ] did you just
say to me you little [ __ ]
i said i'm watching this oh [ __ ] i said
oh i thought i thought you said [ __ ]
your stream oh [ __ ] um oh no
oh no that's that's my bad well long
before he became the most accused
cheater in his genre symphony's journey
as a contentious aim god began when his
grandparents bought him an xbox 360. and
it was in the matchmaking lobbies of
halo 3 and call of duty that he started
to ply his trade now initially symfony
dipped his toes into streaming with
minecraft back in 2013 but after taking
a break for a couple of years he decided
to try it again this time playing h1z1
a game which proved to be an early
stomping ground for a number of eventual
battle royale superstars
and it's important to note that even
back then this kid was cracked
i'm sorry
at a time when brs themselves were on
the up and up symphony was rapidly
gaining steam and it felt as if his
stream was primed to explode
let's go baby whoa
31 dude let's go number one in a bro
let's go dude 2k viewers my highest
viewer count ever
over the course of 2018
fortnite really emerged as twitch's
preeminent battle royale and seeing its
popularity skyrocket inspired symfony to
make the jump fortunately for him the
transition was easy not only had he
retained the shooting skills he'd honed
in h1 but his ability to edit and build
in fortnite was astonishing
watch this watch this flick ready ready
watch watch watch watch watch watch
soon enough symphony's talent had earned
him enough street cred that he was
rubbing shoulders with not only the
biggest names in fortnite but quite
literally the biggest names in streaming
all right forty six quiet here we go all
right nice
ah get him
let's go
four little 34 again let's go that's 2
30. it's a big boy bomb right there
god damn man
look at this
who's symphony sign with you better
someone's better sign up i better talk
to nate's shot man something it's like
if he's not signed if symphony's not
signed with anybody someone sign him
right now unless he doesn't want to
unless he's just playing casually then
but the best part is that symphony
wasn't just shooting the [ __ ] with these
guys
he was styling on him
wait that was actually tifu oh no before
long symphony had cemented himself as
not only a fairly big time creator and a
legit competitor but a terror in his own
right
the kind of streamer that other
streamers were strangely psyched to get
smoked by oh dynamite
sit oh my god i'm a bop please symphony
symphony
well
well that's why they're so sweaty man
um
that guy was a lot better than me i died
a symphony oh my god that's why i died
symphony continued to make waves in 2019
as one of the biggest up-and-coming
personalities in streaming and the
attention he was generating earned him
an exciting opportunity
here we go boys i finally joined an org
and
now you can see it boys hey we joined
nrg baby joining nrg as a content
creator was a dream come true for
symphony he now found himself affiliated
with esports competitors and
personalities whom he respected deeply
in time alongside his partner and fellow
content creator brooke a b
symphony became something in between a
lifestyle and battle royale brand he
orchestrated everything from
star-studded squad ups to intricate
adorable little minecraft pranks to
full-blown proposals oh a little chapel
i feel like a chapel would be
minecraft married who in the world is
getting married he also somehow
skillfully rode this line between
simping big time streamers and
being a big time streamer yo oh my god
oh my god are you actually in phase
wait are you actually sleeping you're
not in face
you just ruined my dreams of playing
with a real phase member
of course it was early into 2020 that
the fortnight craze finally finished
waning and like a lot of br addicts
symphony returned to his original gaming
roots by jumping on board with call of
duty's newest spin on the genre
warzone and as you may have guessed he
was
cracked at that game too
oh one bottom house
oh my okay jesus christ all on your
right on your right now
got him got him gone where's the other
one
let's go
[Applause]
[Applause]
landing
leave me the [ __ ] alone
oh my god guys this guy's really mad at
me and it was whilst clapping kids in
verdansk that symphony's stream really
took off bouncing back from its previous
high to reach unprecedented levels of
popularity unfortunately it was also
after switching to warzone that symphony
reached unprecedented levels
of something else and that something
else was notoriety
you got rest
imagine losing with hacks imagine losing
with hacks
you see symphony had always
always been cracked but as he got bigger
and better a lot of people started to
wonder was this dude actually cheating
if you didn't know symphony
you you probably
would think he's hacking
i even like [ __ ] like this dude
even [ __ ] like this to me is crazy
[Applause]
he just
snapped onto his head
i don't know bro you know what i mean
whether it was on reddit or twitter or
even in his own in-game comms mans was
constantly getting accused of being on
the gear
huskers is the cheater not me now
according to symphony this was all by
design he knew he had otherworldly aim
and since he couldn't seem to convince
everyone that he was legit he figured
why not lean into it go for them content
flicks you know and stir the pot a
little bit
and
that's exactly what he did the clip i
saw this man symphony gets a kill right
and then flicks his wrist up to the sky
and just shoots nothing in the sky
it's bait and
quite literally half of twitter is
falling for it i watched it he bro he
baited my [ __ ] too no he made me through
i said i said wait is he
dude you did not he's he's baiting
everyone bro he even began to cultivate
a persona around his own innate sussness
and packaged his content around it
hey you did that that's him i got him i
got the cheater i got him let's go
i got him he went in the car dude he
just knocked me he just knocked me
i told you we're the better cheater his
org and rg even went so far as to issue
an official response to all of these
accusations which when clicked into
simply implored readers to well
yeah
oh my god
of course no one who actually played
with symphony suspected that he was a
filthy cheat not only because he'd been
around for years and using a face cam so
you could see his big sweeping arm
movements every time he made a flick but
also because according to those who knew
him
it didn't really suit him
personality wise wait tim you you you
weren't even like a little bit like damn
no bro he's a he's an idiot man there's
no way that kid knows how to install an
aimbot yeah there's no shot
at war zone like bro how ridiculous that
people think sims like he's been good in
every game and he'd have to be an
absolute dumbass to cheat on stream
that's how he's always played nobody
that's known sim for
like four or five years like me thinks
he's hacking over time the actual
accusations died down but symphony's
repute notoriety and the memes
surrounding his sussness certainly
did not
blacked out can you help me can you help
me again can you help me get uh half a
million views on youtube um
sure just say just say just admit to
cheating
alleged allegedly i am a cheater
by the end of 2020 symphony let his
contract with nrg expire and was living
it up as a wildly successful fully
independent free agent what's more since
brooke had signed on as one of hundred
thieves creators in the fall of 2019
he'd been living in their content house
all throughout quarantine and was
featured prominently across their wide
array of content let's see if you can do
it with your thumbs you can
we should
today symphony stands as yet another
illustrious example of a suspected
cheater who
upon closer inspection
turned out to just be really really
special what i've actually noticed now
after playing a lot of call of duty with
him tiffany you're actually unbelievably
talented you know i knew that you were a
good fortnight player that's why we
wanted to sign you way back in the day
and i've seen
what you've what you've done in the past
but after watching you adapt so quickly
to warzone it makes sense but perhaps
the most impressive thing about sim is
how easily he's managed to not only
deflect this barrage of negativity
but actually turn it to his advantage
cheating accusations aren't just
disheartening to those who are nutty
enough to receive them
but in some cases
they can be genuinely destructive i've
said it before and i'm actually gonna
say it again i'm glad that i'm not
really good at games
because if i was sim and i had to defend
my ability
that'd be exhausting now that's not to
say that symphony is entirely free from
controversy or that he isn't entirely
blameless when it comes to how he's
conducted himself on stream simply that
overall
he's just a weird
wholesome kid who aside from being
insanely gifted
it's just hella fun to watch
oh my god symphony no shot i'm done i'm
done it's your birthday
nah i'm done dude that's crazy man i
just want to make it now and like no i
don't give a [ __ ]
okay i'm done nah i'm done i'm done dude
[ __ ] your video i'm going back on this
stupid game nah i'm done i'm done i'm
done the kid went from [ __ ] on
[ __ ] in a lo-fi zombie shooter to
unboxing esports branded gucci bags
while standing alongside nadeshot
symphony didn't just quash his
accusations or succeed in spite of them
he capitalized on them and hey if you're
nasty enough to attract that kind of
suspicion in the first place
why not run with it why stop at shaking
the haters off
why not make a buck off him too i'm
going for the ride
is how he's managed to just like
effortlessly
effortlessly jesus effortlessly
effortlessly
effortlessly god damn i need more sleep
dude i woke up at 7 30 this morning
shows